this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular celebrities pop in to have a
drink
sometimes they share stories and even
secrets because as we all know what the
bartender ears is confidential isn't it
some simpler tending bar when in walks
home and I see quite often around the
place
pac-man the pac-man is usually a very
quiet bloke and this time was no
exception
he doesn't make much chat so I just
left him to his drink and all of a
sudden link came up and I'm thinking to
myself oh no this can't be good anything
involving this guy can never be good but
he sits down next to pac-man and they
stop chatting this is interesting and at
one point link stops holding back man's
hand the pac-man doesn't seem to mind
in fact he's sort of into it now usually
I'll don't mind a no questions can't
stuff not a mob business but uh I knew
that pac-man was a married back I mean I
immediately start thinking about mrs.
pac-man and how you know she won't
approve of any of their soap decide to
but my nose in you know not really my
place but I felt I should say something
I said what mister back man up does your
wife know about this I says well me and
my wife we've got an understanding and
that links us oh yeah me and my wife we
cannot understanding - and I'll said are
you sure I mean that that really doesn't
sound like her I says no we got Torah on
those death in fact she's in the back
you want me to go get her I would say
hello this is her so he leaves the room
for a second term affair with her
he's doing all sorts of under the grease
cut jokes that didn't even know existed
yes like thirty of those jokes I'm just
amazed at that
and then finally mrs. pacman returns
sure enough there she is sitting down
shouting with link and I'll just sit boy
I just wanna check you know that your
husband is seeing a link right now she
says oh yeah yeah meatballs Baloo we got
understanding yeah that's what your
husband said to her just as I know it's
a little taboo but you know it's just
the way the backs like to swing things
I'll say okay I guess that's a big
problem then and then all of a sudden
Cupid pops up says Oh mrs. Mann I
haven't seen you in forever
we still go out Thursday night I thought
oh my so well she's seeing other people
can't be much of a problem but uh she
seemed a little hesitant kind of want to
get away from Cupid there she just kind
of quickly nodded and then rushed out
the place very quickly as she rushed out
so quickly and leaked the sort thought
so too but just before we can even think
about it pac-man came back in he said
what's my wife and we said yeah he says
she's straightened everything out I said
yeah I got everything straightened out
the Cuba comes up this tobacco makes
this point you've got the world's pill
this one you know that Isis on no place
is actually I'm gonna give a call right
now if that's not you know too
inappropriate
pac-man looks left and right so it's
actually that wouldn't be very
appropriate if it says why well she's on
her way to the car right now Chile's
turns off her phone every time she's on
her way to the car so it probably won't
be on anyway
but says oh it's a shame want to tell
her to bring the extra strength glue and
pellets that make you who oughta blue
and he says you know what maybe she is
out there
let me go get a real quick but
immediately Lincoln Heights don't look
at each other like this is a little
strange pac-man and mrs. pacman are
never in the same room
are they within a few seconds mrs.
pac-man comes back at them behold
there's no mr. pac-man with her she
flirts with cubital ooh big gives him a
bathtub when I printed goddesses behind
and I hear cupid distinctly whisper into
her ear
maybe tonight's the night I'll finally
consult and she just smiles and pitches
his I know it wasn't his chief but I
digress qubit leaves the room and now
mrs. man is stuck with us again link and
I will give a nervous and I'll say boy
where's y'all's Ben right now she's in
the bathroom
also yeah where were you just a few
minutes ago she said the pokeball link
says I never see any pictures are you
two together
she says a camera shy plus your wedding
ring I lost it you didn't get another
one that it made it I so what's your
major thing she said woman pack woman
Eielson your pack man aren't you she
said no no I don't know what you're
talking about sir games up mr. P we know
it's you and takes off the bow wipes off
the lipstick Hilton mr. P was packed man
and mrs. pacman and all just realize I'm
in the crying video game The Crying Game
you say cuz I was about you're gonna get
it lady you're gonna laugh that's why of
course ask boy what are you doing this
place says well yeah ever wondered
but it's like to be two people accessor
but my wife certainly has he sounds very
deliberate to be any gender you won't
have any gender you want anytime you
want not said all right that's all dandy
and good but uh just what gender are you
anyway
like said it better be a honking madman
he said the truth of the matter is the
packs don't have a gender in fact we
don't even have private moms that's all
I can dolls down there which link
something says we'll wait a minute how
did we a says the strap-ons he gets him
at a specially made mr. Potato Head sure
just strap it on take it off that's ugly
realize why I'm supposed to buy my own
business a pacman assurelink a said boy
plus don't find you attractive I'll
still think you're incredibly handsome
and I think I even have feelings for you
so come on can't we patch this up like I
said sorry you lost me at I had feelings
for you he said the attractiveness in
handsomeness I could go along with that
but the feelings that's just to cleave
only link is such a break he tells
pac-man he says I'm gonna go find Cuban
and Hulk up and tell the truth you're on
your letterhead back mrs. white what
about a Triforce of love Lex isn't gonna
be a duplex of disappointment which I
guess logically so it makes more sense
and for what that Cupid does get the
better BJ with that fountain of a night
seriously digressive so pac-man is
sitting there tears in his eyes and I
see audience FK there's plenty of other
corn puffs in the cereal wolf pack man
said I know I know but I guess in the
end I still have the ghost
assai you and the ghosts are seeing each
other is of course we all have to play
the game I chase them around and then I
eat them out as I here's your bill is he
alone strange things as a ball to them
see a lot strange things at the pixel
Palace so I see a lot of strange things
as a bartender pixel palace that ain't
no lie
you